So ready. One of my favorite subjects after football obviously is, um,
as you know,
is black holes and there's over the last sort of six months or so there's been
some quite big black hole news. And I think it's time that, um,
that we shared it with you go, I'm all ears what's going on. So, so as you know,
I mean, this there's been a problem. That's kind of been around my,
my entire life basically. And it's the famous black hole information paradox,
uh, which so Hawking first or proposed it around the time I was born about,
about to, well, should I say how long ago, mid seventies it was. Um,
and so Hawking spent his whole life trying to solve this problem.
Never quite managed it. Well, it seems that in the last year or so, uh, we,
I think we're there. I think it's been sold. What is the problem in very,
in a nutshell, it's that black holes seem to lose information.
They seem to have sort of information seems to disappear inside black holes. Um,
and that kind of breaks fundamentally the laws of quantum mechanics,
quantum mechanics basically tells you that, um, you can't lose information.
What goes in must come out.
So Hawking proposed that you seem to see evidence that black holes were actually
losing this information. And he figured, well,
that means that breaking quantum mechanics, this is like sacrilege.
And he went to physics assess information. What do they mean?
You don't mean like three bottles of milk or the Liverpool game will
score was three to like, what is information?
I can absolutely mean that. So let, let me give you an example.
I've actually come prepared with an, with an example.
So obviously what I was going to talk about information,
what we really want to talk about is, is in the context of entropy.
So I'm Jordan lockdown. I've been homeschooling my kids and, uh,
we've been doing some experiments. I'm not very much,
I'm not very good experimentalists. I'm no film Moriarty. Right? And,
but we've been trying a few. One of the ones we did was we, um,
balancing liquids of different density on top of one another.
Can you see that radio?
I've got a liquid that I've got the blue liquid on top of the,
the red liquid and then the other one, it's the other way round.
You can't quite see it as well, but the red liquid is on top. Okay.
So we've got two different liquids. These look very different, right?
These two liquids,
they look very different and you would say they're completely different States.
But what I can do is of course I can stay the liquid. Right.
And I can stay the other one. All right. And now if I show you them,
you can't tell the difference between those guys, right?
They look exactly the same.
You can't tell whether this one was the one that had the blue on top or this one
was the one that had the blue on top. It's impossible to tell, right?
Just by looking at it.
So the measurements that you're doing just by staring at this thing,
it could be either state that created it could have been the one with the red on
top of it. It could have been the one in the blue on top.
There could be lots of other ways you could have created that same sort of gunky
mess, right. And that gives the entropy.
This is like an uncertainty I sort of missing information and stuff you don't
know, just by, based on the measurements that you're doing of this object.
Similarly, you know,
you have that sort of set of headphones that are all tangled.
There could have been loads of different ways they could have gotten to that
roughly tangled state that gives this entropy in some sense of missing
information. Now, of course, in the case of this, this liquid,
I could sort of dive inside and unpick the microscopic structure of the whole
thing and extract the information out of whether it was blue on top of the star
or red on top. I could in principle get that out of it.
Yeah.
So you're talking about almost like doing the ultimate crime scene investigation
and unpicking. This came from that direction.
And this came from that direction and figuring out all this stuff to say, Oh,
it was red and blue at the start.
You could do that with the case of that, that the case of this thing, right.
In the case of a black hole, however,
it really does hide the information because you can't get anything out of a
black hole.
You can't go in and don't pick the information and feed it to the outside.
So to see how black holes do carry entropy, like,
let me imagine a scenario, right?
Suppose you wake up one morning and there's a black hole at the bottom of your
garden. Right. And okay. It's quite alarming.
And probably it's going to sort of tell you apart,
but it's sort of tidal effects if you get too close to it,
but let's say you don't get too close. And the next day you wake up again,
the black hole is still there, but it's grown by say the massive in elephants.
Okay. Now how would you know that it's swallowed an elephant?
Did it swallow an elephant or maybe did it swallow a car with the same mass or
something else with the same mess? There's no way that you can know, right?
Because when you do a sort of measurements on a black hole,
the only things that you can measure are its massive charge and its angular
momentum.
So there's literally no way you can tell whether it was made by an elephant or
made by a car.
There's no measurement you can do on that black hole that will tell you that it
will look the same.
Tony.
W why is this not just a problem of access to the information
rather than the existence of the information.
Ready? Okay. So if that was all I told you, then you'd say, yeah, that's,
it's just hidden behind the black hole of I dived inside.
I find that information, everything would be fine. It'd be no problem. Okay,
great.
The trouble is Hawking then told us that black holes actually radiate that
they'll evaporate. Okay.
So you have this process by which you think of pairs of particles being produced
near the event horizon and those particles,
one particle due to in certain principle might find itself just outside one,
just inside the outside guy,
escapes the inside guy falls in and this black hole evaporates.
It starts to lose its mass. That radiation that it produces,
it's really completely random in some sense. So,
so know at the event horizon where this, all this magic is happening, you know,
there's not any,
it could be this particle that went out or it could be the other one that went
out. It's totally random. The only thing that the,
the radiation sees is the shape of the space time,
the geometry of the space time from that radiation,
you can't extract that there was a,
it was made from a car that hole was made from a car or that it was made from an
elephant. You can't get that from the radiation.
And then eventually the black hole evaporates away completely.
And all you're left with is the radiation. Okay. Which I've just said,
and Hawking told us, doesn't contain the information that you need.
So the information is disappeared, which is disaster for quantum mechanics.
I've got one more.
Uh, half-baked Brady theory as to how you could find that the information when I
woke up on the second morning and the black hole is heavier,
could I not do a census of everything outside the black hole and say, Oh,
there's one less elephant in the solar system.
It must be an elephant that fell in.
Um, no, no. Um, okay.
If you have two regions of space that are separated from one another,
if you have a pure concept state over the whole space right then,
and then you separate them, the two regions,
there could be information in this region,
which relies on knowledge of this region and vice versa. Okay.
So if you separate the two regions,
you can have missing information in this and missing information in this,
but they kind of compensate for one another. They account for one another,
which is kind of what you're asking. Can I do that?
And that ought to be what happens. That absolutely ought to be what happens,
but hockey's calculation suggested that it's not what happens. Okay.
So it's fair. It's a fair point. What you said. Yes.
Isn't the information just to see,
can I just sort of account for the missing information on one side versus the
other side and everything takes care of itself.
That's what content mechanics demands that should be able to do in some sense,
Hawking said, well, here's the calculation. Show me how it's done.
I can't do it.
All right then. So let's,
let's not get too bogged down in all my stupid questions.
Let's talk about what's actually happened.
What's the news what's been happening recently. That's got you excited.
If we're going to get to that, kind of tell you about Hawking's beds. Okay.
So Hawkings spent his whole life trying to solve this problem. Okay.
And he was convinced for time, that information was lost inside black holes.
And he had a human Kip Thorne who you probably know from the film,
interstellar had a bet with a press school from Caltech
over whether the information was lost on that. So Hawking him Fon said,
said that it would be lost. Press Gill said no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't be silly. Quantum mechanics is too precious. No way it's been lost.
It's going to get lost. It will be surveilled survived somehow this information.
So how,
and spend a lot of time trying to figure out one way or another then became
convinced it probably was survived,
but couldn't work out how came up with some ideas,
how to the point where he ended up paying the out the bets to press skill,
Kip, Thorne, they thought the Hawkins ideas weren't quite right. I mean,
you refuse to pay the bats. Um, it sends out hoagies ideas weren't right.
Um, but over the years, people have become convinced that information was, uh,
you know, wasn't lost, but not really sure how it,
how it wasn't lost if you see what I mean. So then yeah. Right. What's the news.
We seem to figure it out how it's not lost. Okay. So.
So information is presented to this.
Breakthrough has come from, from two teams, one on the East coast of America,
uh, centered around Princeton and one, one around Stanford on the West coast.
So the Princeton team did a really nice review just last week, actually,
where they gave a really nice analogy for how, how this information is, is,
is preserved. Okay. So the story goes, you have, um, you have some,
some Valerie's, he's easy. He lives in a,
in a posh house and it's full of beautiful, extremely valuable paintings. Okay.
So he's um, but he has no money. Okay. So he, but he wants to,
he wants to show off his shelf, his wealth, but he has no cash.
He's just got these paintings. He's really valuable paintings. So he says, okay,
then I'm going to borrow some money off the people of the town. Okay.
So he says, right, borrow some money off the people at town,
get some cash that way. And as he he'll use the paintings as a guarantee,
okay. So he does that.
He gets this cash and he throws lavish parties, the people of the town,
meanwhile,
they no longer have any cash because they've lent it all to the guy in the
house. Okay. So they're certainly not throwing lavish parties.
They're living very frugally. So you look at this from the outside and you say,
well, who's, who's um, who's the guys, the towns, people seem quite poor here.
Right? They don't seem very rich, but of course that's not true. They are rich.
They kind of, because they, you know, they, they, they kind of own in a sense,
those paintings that are locked inside the house, they're their paintings.
And this is analogous to what's happening with the black hole.
So in the analogy, the house is the black hole. Okay.
The townspeople are like the radiation and the, um, the,
the wealth of the townspeople.
It's the quantum information that's stored in that radiation. So very naively,
you look at this and you think that the townspeople are poor or that the
radiation has not doesn't have much quantum information, but actually it does.
Okay. It somehow got access to the interior of the black hole.
In the case of the analogy, the, the, the sort of towns,
people actually have much more wealth than you can secretly see that by looking
at maybe the record of the loan,
the record of the loan will show that they have some connection with the,
with the inside of the house. It's my elephant all over again.
Of course he had to be there. It had to be right,
but now let's see how it happened. This is great. This is,
this is where it gets beautiful. How does that play out in the black hole case?
Okay.
How does the radiation make that connection to the interior of the black hole?
That it seems like you shouldn't be allowed that, right?
Because this is violating locality and space and time,
but what happens is the following.
There's an Island forms inside the black hole. I've kind of,
I sort of read inside the black hole and they call it the Island.
And that kind of, you start to think of that, not as part of the black hole,
but was part of the radiation itself.
The radiation makes a connection to this Island through a wormhole.
I love wormholes. Right? That's how it makes it. So how do you,
how does the information leak out? Well,
what you would do is you would do some complicated
sorts of measurements and it can be exponentially complicated, right?
Measurements on the, on the Hawking radiation, right? And effectively,
you're creating this wormhole,
which then accesses the interior of the black hole and you're,
and you can get the information out.
You can figure out whether it was made from it, an elephant or a car. Now,
wormholes, they're really hard to produce.
You absolutely cannot produce them at all until the black hole is radiated
away, roughly half its size, okay, it's passed this time called the page time.
But after that, you can start to create them and it gets easier to create them.
And actually, these,
these guys have shown that in some simple toy models of gravity,
these wormholes are there.
And actually they dominate the behavior at late times and Hawking never knew
about them. And that's why he made the wrong conclusion.
To go back to the painting analogy. You told,
you told me when a black hole radiates, Hawking radiation.
It's a random app.
There's no control over what particles will happen to form on one side of the
event, horizon or the other. And that's why information perhaps was being lost.
And if we are going to attach that to the analogy of our rich painting owner,
surely the problem here is there's no control over whether he's going to pay
back the loan, payback the guarantee,
because the money coming back out to the townspeople has now been randomized.
Right. Okay. And, and, and here is the,
it is difficult to get the information out in a black hole.
And it might be very difficult to get the money back from the,
from the town specified the doors locked, you know, set up a barricade,
but it's not impossible. It's there. Okay. It's there.
And so the way they and the guys outside can prove that, well, they say, look,
here's the document here. Here is I made this loan.
If you're looking at black hole, you need to create this web hole to get in.
So Tony, if we were creating a very, very fantasy situation here,
and I was going to give you infinite, uh,
tools and measurement devices and spaceships and all the things you could
possibly want. Right. And I said, all right,
I'm going to send you out to that black hole somewhere in the universe.
Tell me what went down, get the information back for me. All right.
I want to know the story. What are you doing? Are you looking for like,
are you looking for a worm hole? Is the wormhole near the black hole? What,
like, how would you go about this investigation? Yeah.
So it's really, so that's really, really difficult. Um, so firstly,
if the black hole hasn't radiated enough of its, of its size away,
then you can't do it at all.
It's just impossible to get the information out if it's gone past a certain
point. So you, you know, you can pass a certain stage past this page time, then,
then indeed you can. Um, but it's,
it's exponentially difficult to do and it gets, it gets easier and easier,
but it's still really, really hard to unpick that, to do.
You basically have to do a quantum measurements of the radiation,
and you're trying to sort of extract the nature of the state.
Um, but it's really, really difficult to, you know,
maybe in terms of practical purposes, maybe impossible, but that doesn't matter.
The point is, is in principle, is it possible? And it is possible.
And they showed that these wormholes do actually dominate.
In this in principle scenario,
are you the worm to go inside the black hole and make measurements or measuring
what comes out of the worm?
So if we're going to be really,
really precise about the way you can think of it is is this the following?
So the radiation, um, you know, naively,
it contains all this missing information. It's, it's,
it's what we call a mixed state and quantum mechanics.
It seems very impure in a sense, uh, all this missing,
all these missing ingredients, what the wormhole does,
it connects it with particles that were once in tangled with it,
and that purifies the state.
So the wormhole literally enables you to purify the radiation. So,
so you've got all this stuff, which is all random over here.
It used to be connected to stuff that was over here, right.
But now it's been disconnected,
but actually the wormhole reconnects them and purifies the quantum state.
And so he actually has all the, it doesn't have any,
it doesn't have the missing information that you thought it had.
Tony is this breakthrough a situation whereby it's like a
new discovery and an advance that could be used to, you know,
understand things better and maybe do things in the future?
Or is this more just a case of, we found a theoretical loophole.
That means the current system we're clinging to still works. So don't worry.
There's no exception go about your business.
Yeah. That's a really interesting question because I think,
I think one of the things about the black hole information paradox that people
always said was the black all in information practice is so profound.
It's so incredible that when we solve it and I'm going to say it,
I think we have solved it. Okay. That when we solve it,
it will reveal something dramatic about space and time. That's yours.
I'll say something about quantum gravity, something like that right now,
I don't think that's happened. And the reason is, is so,
so Hawking himself could have actually got this solution without any knowledge
of quantum gravity. It doesn't rely on quantum gravity.
One of the great ideas that came from looking at the information products was
this idea of holography. Uh, you know, that that's actually,
the information is stored on the boundary of space time. You know, that the,
you know,
you can basically describe gravity by space of stuff on the boundary of space
time, and that could come up.
And that was certainly an inspiration for these ideas,
but it doesn't rely on it. It doesn't rely on it. You didn't need any of that.
So in a way it's, that makes it beautifully simple.
The solution makes it feel right,
but where's the amazing new insight that we were promised. Well, we don't know.
Maybe it's very early days yet. There is a little strange thing going on.
That's sitting in there, which is this, this idea that, um,
there's almost like a randomness to Quantico suggest there might be a
randomness to quantum gravity that, that when you talk about quantum gravity,
maybe the theory, isn't just one theory.
It might be like what we call an ensemble of theories, the theories itself,
there's a little sort of technical subtlety in there in terms of the kinds of
theories they played with to solve this. There's called JT gravity,
which have this property,
but is that something that you're going to need for the sort of extended to sort
of fall four dimensional general relativity and so on? Maybe
we don't know that might be the sort of little smoking on that saying, ah,
that's the really, that's the nugget that's going to take us,
give us that sort of, you know, what we were promised, uh, from the,
from a solution to the information paradox.
When you look through what they've published and what they've discovered, what,
what do you think the leap or the clever thing they thought of was that all the
men and women before didn't think of, like, what's the thing you look at and go,
ah, yes. Clever.
As ever. It's not just one thing, right. I've talked about.
I mentioned the holographic principle, the idea that, that, that all this,
that you can describe gravity with a theory on the boundary of the space-time,
that's clearly been a major inspiration of major ingredients in terms of
understanding in the end, we didn't need it,
but in getting there in the journey, it was crucially important. Um,
there was a new way of thinking about entropy, which was,
came from these guys Ryo and tuck unagi. Um, that was really important,
but actually I want to highlight the contribution of, of,
of one guy in particular who's um, is a young English guy.
And I'm not just saying that because I'm biased. Right. Um, but he's, uh,
he's actually just a PhD student at Stanford, but actually his work,
this guy called Jeff Pennington, his work, um, that he did it.
Some of it she did on his own was really sort of a prelim to a lot of this.
And then he's now on the papers with the, that finally seemed to have solved it,
but it was the work he was doing before, seems to be really,
really important as well.
So in a way it's like the new kid on the block just finally sent everybody over
the line. And, um,
I think we've got an absolute star in the making there, if I'm honest. Um,
and funnily enough, I was actually, I had some discussions with him and, uh,
turns out he, he lived around the corner from,
from where Emma Watson went to school now and Watson who plays Hermione in
Harry Potter films. Uh, I think that the sisters may,
his sister may have hung around in a similar circle or something,
but it sort of makes me laugh. It's like,
did she know there was a real wizard actually just around the corner.
You mentioned that wormholes have been a key part of this.
What is a wormhole? I always thought a wormhole is somewhere where like,
you know, you put your hand in the hole here in, on earth and,
and it comes out on the other side of the universe or something that had like
these like ultimate shortcuts. Am I right?
Or are they something a bit more technical?
Exactly what it is. Of course, if we're going to be brutally honest, um,
these calculations are not really done in space time,
they're done in space space.
You've actually flipped 10 time into imaginary time.
That's how you do these calculations.
So these are really wormholes in those scenarios. Um,
it's a sign of technical detail that I, I, you know,
I don't want to get bogged down in. Um, but yeah,
it's exactly what you would normally think of a worst based time where I'm at
least there's something like that.
Something that connects to regions of space and these calculations,
it's connecting to regions of space,
but there is no time in these settles because you've,
you've gone to imaginary time. Um, but yeah, that's, that's.
That's exactly what they are. Imaginary time.
Thanks for dropping that bomb shot right at the end. Well,
there's all these details, right? You do that. I spent two days each,
I don't pick them the extra dimensions angle.
Okay.
The difference between those sorts of black holes,
the astrophysical black holes and the kind that you might produce, the LHC, uh,
those are, those are very large. They're very large black holes. Okay.
They've been formed from Stella collapsed, you know,
death of a star collapses and forms of black holes.